today I'm filing applications for
warrants of arrest before pre-trial
chamber one we will bring you back to
your fingertips meaning on that day when
Allah is so precise when it comes to our
fingertip how do you think the judgment
is going to be the judgment is also
going to be ultimately
perfect brothers and sisters just
imagine for a second that you give £10
in donation and that £10 is used to buy
food or bricks or whatever to help the
people in Gaza but then just imagine
this amazing be that you want to do but
we turn it into a money-making machine
how the W is exactly that they take your
money and the money that we are going to
put in in this W this building and every
single time the money generated from
that W that building is going to go to
our Palestinian brothers and sisters for
the next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years
and this will be a form of
true click the link below and
donate brothers and sisters and dear
friends I was just out with my wife just
doing a little shopping aldah and we I
got the news that icj have declared a um
they doing an arrest warrant on Benjamin
Netanyahu and his uh scumback sidan um
here is the video and I'm just going to
come and mention something from and why
is so important that we don't put our
Reliance and Trust on the icj or anyone
for that matter here's the video today
I'm filing applications for warrants of
arrest before pre-trial chamber one of
the international criminal court in the
situation in the state of Palestine I
read reasonable grounds to believe on
the basis of evidence collected and
examined by my office that Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu and Minister of Defense yuav
Galant bear criminal
responsibility for the following
International crimes committed on the
territory of the State of Palestine from
at least the 8th of October
2023 the crimes include starvation of
civilians as a method of warfare
willfully causing great suffering
Serious injury to body or health or
cruel
treatment willful killing or murder and
intentionally directing attacks against
a civilian
population as well as crimes against
humanity of extermination and or murder
persecution and allegations of crimes of
committing other inhuman Acts
it's alleged that these crimes were
committed in the context of the ongoing
armed conflict and as part of a
widespread and systematic attack against
the civilian population of Gaza so guys
what you just saw thish for yourself
from sisters Allah subh inah why does
Allah
say the owner of the day of judgment why
does Allah subhana say that because he
allow telling us that he is the owner of
that day not icj whoever is for that
matter and I'm not trying to speak
either of them can ever do True Justice
and we know that yes we know with their
uh verdicts Etc of um false accusations
that they have done to Hamas of rape Etc
uh it's clear with that so Subhan Allah
Allah subhana wa tala is saying that why
is the day own of the day of judgment
because True Justice is going to be
served there why because if you look at
Quran let me read it for you guys
Allah with the name of Allah the most
merci very merciful I swear by the day
of resurrection and I swear by the self
reproaching conscious that Resurrection
is a reality does man think that we
would never reassemble his bones why
reassembling the bones because brothers
and sisters that day do you really think
Allah subhana is a God that has is
purposeless there is a purpose of
reassemble because there's going to be a
day of judgment do you really think
you're going to get away with the
atrocities that You' committed in Gaza
Benjamin Netanyahu and anyone that's
doing evil or anyone that's wronged you
do you think they're going to get away
with it do you really think that Allah
is going to allow that all the evil
these individuals have done they're just
going to get it away they're going to
die and it's going to come to an end no
why can and says why can we not do so
why we are able to even put together his
fingertips perfectly why is Allah
mention fingertips because we have the
fingerprint which is unique to every
single one of us the detail the
attention to detail to even the
fingertips Allah saying forget the bones
forget the flesh forget BR you we will
bring you back to your fingertips
meaning on that day when Allah so
precise when it comes to our fingertips
how do you think the judgment is going
to be the judgment is also going to be
ultimately perfect because that's is an
attribute that belongs to allaha the
judgment is going to be absolutely
perfect and then but man wishes to go on
violating Allah's injunctions even in
the future ahead of him he asked when
will be the day of Resurrection so when
will the and then it says so when the
eyes will be doled and the moon will
lose its light and the Sun and the Moon
will be joined together on that day man
will say where to escape Benjamin nanah
and all of you guys then you will say
where will you escape to there's no way
to escape Allah's judgment and I'll
finish on this note never there will be
no refuge at at all on that day on that
day towards your Lord will be the
destination of every man man will be
informed of what he sent ahead and what
what he left behind so Allah subhana wa
tala may Allah subh deal with these
people on this earth and the Hereafter
but true judgment is going to be on that
day that day when we see it and even
Allah says in that the Believers will be
on reclining sers and looking if the
disbelievers the Hostile ones have been
paid back for what they did that's what
Allah says in so do not lose hope do not
put your trust in anyone True Justice is
going to
happen the owner of the day of judgment
where no one will be intervening or
trying to cheat Justice may Allah bless
and preserve you guys in